[موسيقى]
لماذا اصبح النظام الغذائي موضوعا محتدما
في عالم السياسه ولماذا اصبحت مناصره
القضايا البيئيه مصدر ازعاج للعديد من
السياسيين ومن قرر ان النباتيين واكلي
اللحوم على طرفي نقيد في مقياس التقدم
الاخلاقي او ان البيئي هو اكثر حرصا على
مستقبل الارض من غيره
لم تعد احتجاجات ناشطي البيئه احتجاجات
خفيفه او عابره فان تكون نباتيا او مناصرا
لقضيه المناخ اصبح جزءا من هويه يغذيها
تصاعد الاستقطاب السياسي الحاصل في العالم
تحت شعارات العداله الاجتماعيه وجد
النباتيون والبيئيون ارضيه مشتركه مع
الاحزاب اليسريه التي باتت قضاياها هدفا
للشعبوين واليمين الصاعد
وبين التطرف هنا وافكار متطرفه هناك تحولت
النباتيه وقضايا المناخ من قضايا ذات
اهداف ساميه الى تحركات ذات طابع سياسي
واسلوب حياه يعبر عن تلك الهويه
النباتيه هي فلسفه تحاول منح الحيوانات
حقوقا اساسيه تحديدا حقهم في جسدهم وحقهم
في المحافظه على حياتهم في اساسها هي
طريقه تعبير واسلوب تفكير يسعى الى الحد
بقدر الامكان من استغلال واستخدام
الحيوانات
اخشى من ان يدمر كل ما اعرفه واحبه كشخص
مازال يافعا فان مستقبلي على المحك اشخاص
مثلي ليس لديهم رفاهيه الجلوس على الهامش
فيما امامنا جيل المستقبل انا ساعيش هذا
المستقبل وانا مرعوبه من ان ازمه المناخ
ستقتلني وهي تقتل الناس بالفعل اليوم
اذكرك
هومي
[موسيقى]
حاليا في المملكه المتحده يوجد نحو 26% من
الفئه العمريه بين 18 واربعه وعشرين عاما
ايجيل زي يعرفون انفسهم بانهم نباتيون
خلال خمس سنوات سيكون النباتيون هم من
سيقود هذا التغيير
قال الراحل طوني عن الحركات الاجتماعيه ان
الناس في البدايه تتجاهلك مرارا ثم تبدا
بالقول انك مجنون ثم يرونك خطيرا ثم هناك
وقفه ثم لا تجد احدا للاختلاف معك
بريطانيا من بين الدول التي شهدت خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه وقفات احتجاجيه
بيئيه تخريبيه احيانا ومتطرفه احيانا اخرى
[موسيقى]
جدل قديم متجدد حول ارهاب ورهاب نباتيين
والبيئيين يدور هنا في بريطانيا التي تعد
مركزا تقليديا للناشطين على اختلاف
دوافعهم وتنوع قضاياهم
[موسيقى]
نورينا واحده من مجموعه من النباتين الذين
قابلناهم في لندن رغم قساوه مشهد الطير
المقتول الذي تحمله لكن بالنسبه اليها فان
هذه الحملات ما هي الا انعكاس لقساوه ما
يجري خلف ابواب مزارع الحيوانات المغلقه
يستمر الانسان في خيانه هذه الحيوانات عن
طريق نزع ريشها بابشع طريقه
انا ناشط لانني كنت ادعي انني اهتم
بالحيوانات الطوال حياتي ثم ادركت انني
منافق كيف يمكنك ان تحب كائنا ما وانت
تاكله ثلاث مرات في اليوم
تجمعات اسبوعيه تنسيق مسبق يافطات
ومنشورات معده اتفاق على الخطه ثم
الانطلاق
يؤكدون انه لا نيه لهم للاشتباك مع احد
هدفهم اليوم توعيه الناس ضد اكل لحوم طيور
الديك الرومي فقط
لكن الامور لا تسير دائما وفق الخطه فهم
غير مرحب بهم في هذا المتجر صحيح طردوا من
المكان لكن بالنسبه اليهم نجاحهم اليوم
يكمن في ايصال الرساله التي جاءوا من
اجلها
نحن في القرن الحادي والعشرين ولا يحتاج
الناس الى قتل الحيوانات او تناول الحليب
او الذبح ولا يحتاجون الى اجراء التجارب
عليها كما ليس من الضروري ارتداء
الحيوانات للازياء بات لدينا البديل لكل
شيء
خارج المتجر يكملون لا يستطيع احد من
المسؤولين ايقافهم هنا نظرات التعاطف
واضحه على الماره لكن نظرات الاستهجان
تبدو اكثر وضوحا من قبل الفيجن فوبز او ما
باتا يعرف بمرهابين نباتيين تسمعهم بين
الحين والاخر ينعتون الناشطين بكلمات
بذيئه
انا شخصيا لا اتفق معهم اعتقد انه من
الجيد ان ياكل الناس الديك الرومي لا باس
اذا كانوا يريدون ان ياكلوا ما يريدون اذا
لم يزعجهم ذلك فهو عالم حر
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يجب ان تكون خيارات الناس
مفتوحه لناحيه ما ياكلونه ينبغي ان يكونوا
قادرين على الحصول على ما يريدون اذا اراد
الناس تناول اللحوم والديك الرومي فيجب ان
يكون قادرين على ذلك
الطعام امر شخصي للغايه واعتقد انه عندما
نشعر الناس بالعار او مشاعر الذم بين
الافراد فهذا عاده يكون طريقا صعبا للغايه
لان ذلك يمكن ان يجلب معه الكثير من الغضب
وردود الفعل القويه جدا من مثلا الفيجان
فوبيا
بعد اخذ قسط من الراحه اعادوا تجميع
صفوفهم هذه المره استعدادا للاحتجاج على
استخدام الفراء من قبل احد المتاجر
الراقيه في لندن
يجول الناشطون هؤلاء في شوارع لندن مره او
مرتين او حتى عده مرات امام المتاجر التي
يقولون بانها تستخدم اساليب تنتهك حقوق
الحيوانات في انتاج الملابس
قد يقال الكثير عن النباتيه لكن الاكيد
انها ليست توجها جديدا فالنباتيه اسلوب
حياه ظهر في حضارات وطبعا فلسفات عده على
مر التاريخ ولكن مع بروز انماط جديده
للحياه تركز على النظام الصحي وتحارب
التدهور المناخي بدات النباتيه تاخذ طابع
الحركه السياسيه الشامله التي برزت فيها
تيارات اكثر تشددا
ازدادت شعبيه الحركات المناصره للنباتيين
في بريطانيا في الاونه الاخيره امر متوقع
مع ارتفاع اعداد النباتيين بنسبه 300
في غضون 10 سنوات خلال العقد الماضي ولكن
ما مدى تاثير استهلاك اللحوم على البيئه
وجدت دراسه ان النظام الغذائي العالمي
مسؤول عن 21 الى 37% من انبعاثات الغازات
الدافئه فيما استهلاك اللحوم يعد سببا
رئيسيا الانبعاثات غازات الميثان وثاني
اكسيد الكربون واكسيد النيتروز هذه
الغازات تسهم في تغير المناخ مثل الاحتباس
الحراري وتربيه المواشي تعد في طليعه
الاسباب التي ترفع نسبه هذه الغازات
والحل بحسب الدراسه التحول الى نظام نباتي
لذا هل يمكن القول ان الحفاظ على مستقبل
الازمه المناخيه معتمد على جهود البيئيين
والنباتيين وان كان كذلك لماذا لا يشعر
الناس بالامتنان لهم
لا شك ان المجتمع النباتي والبيئي يشعر
بانه اكثر تقدميا غيره لكنهم في الوقت
نفسه ربما اكثر وحده من غيرهم
هناك بحوث تشير الى ان التحول الى
النباتيه يزيد بالفرص في المعاناه من
الوحده لانك تلقائيا تبتعد عن مائده
العشاء وتشعر بالوحده لذا نحاول هنا في
جريزر مساعدتهم واصالهم بنباتيين اخرين
فكان من الضروري ايجاد مساحات خاصه بهم
مطاعم ومنتجات غذائيه نباتيه بالكامل وحتى
تطبيقات المواعده انشئت للنباتيين
والبيئيين
لدينا الكثير من قصص النجاح شهدنا عددا من
الزيجات كما اصبح لدينا اطفال غريزر كما
نسميهم ليس في المملكه المتحده فقط وانما
في انحاء مختلفه من العالم فالمنصه ليست
للمواعده فقط وانما لمساعده الناس على
ايجاد اصدقاء
[موسيقى]
بقى هي مش حلوه هايدي الاسلوب هيدا منه
حلو بس انه كل واحد عنده رايه الشخصي وكل
واحد شو بيرتاح بياكل بس انه اجباري لا ما
بعتقد انا بوافق على هالراي والله الراي
الصحيح يعني الانسان حسب طبيعته طبيعه
الانسان هو في ناس نباتيين يعني من
طبيعتهم وفي ناس لا يحبون ياكلون كل شي في
الحياه يعني
فشي مو اجباري يعني هذا اختياري للناس
[موسيقى]
عراب النباتيين في بريطانيا ليس ناشطا فقط
وانما مؤثر باتا يتابعه الالاف على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من خلال فيديوهات
تثقيفيه اصبح اد مصدر الهام للعديد من
النباتيين الذين وجدوا فيه صوتا قادرا على
ايصال الرساله التي فشل احيانا في ايصالها
لا يمكن انكار وجود تسيس كبير للنباتي
اليوم واعتقد يحدث في الولايات المتحده
اكثر من بريطانيا اوروبا الغربيه بشكل عام
واعتقد ان السبب وراء ذلك وانه عندما تقوم
بتسييس شيء ما يصبح من السهل رسم خطوط
المعركه لذلك اذا كان لديك اشخاص من مختلف
الاطياف السياسيه يختلفون على فكره ما فمن
خلال تسييسها يمكنهم تحريك الدوائر
السياسيه ضدها واعتقد ان ذلك تكتيك رخيص
نوعا ما يتجاهل فضائل النظام النباتي
ونامل ان يكون هناك المزيد والمزيد من
الناس يتبنون النباتيه من مختلف الاطياف
السياسيه
من خلال تسييس النباتيه يصبح اختلاف
الاراء السياسيه حول القضايا البيئيه هو
المحرك الاساسي لها وحتى الوصول الى حل
للخلافات السياسيه يبدو ان القضيه
الاساسيه تضيع في التفاصيل وهي ان اكل
اللحوم المصنعه هو النوع الاكثر اهدارا
واضرارا بيئيا
ليست النباتيه وحدها التي تدق ناقوس خطر
الكارثه البيئيه التي يتجه اليها العالم
حيث انبثقت عن فلسفتها مجموعات اخرى تفرعت
في قضاياها وتطرفت في اساليبها
لم يمضي على خروج من السجن بكفاله سوى
بضعه اسابيع كانت واحده من بين العشرات من
الناشطين الذين اعتقلوا بعد قطعهم طريقا
سريعا في لندن والقاء الطعام على لوحات
فنيه مشهوره احتجاجا على استخراج الوقود
الاحفوري خرجت فيبي لتجد ان لها قاعده
شعبيه بين العديد من الماره يقفون بين
الحين والاخر يباركون لها ما فعلته في
المعرض الوطني في اكتوبر الماضي
لا يزال غريبا القول انني دخلت السجن انا
لست مجرمه انا مجرد شابه خائفه واحاول
المكافحه من اجل مستقبلي الحكومه تخاطر
بكل شيء بتجاهلها علمائها ومستشاريهم كم
عدد الخبراء الذين يحتاجون حتى يتسنى
للعوده الى حياه الطبيعيه الطلابيه هل
تعتقدين ان الذهاب الى السجن والاعتقال
والذهاب الى المحكمه امر ممتع الامر ليس
كذلك ولكن لا يمكنني التراجع
نشاط المناخيين والنباتيين التخريبي كقطع
الطرقات او اقتحام مطاعم تقدم اللحوم وصلت
الى اروقه صنع القرار التي وجدت في
افعالهم سببا لاتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه قالت
انها تحمل اكثريه من افعال الاقليه التي
باتت تعرق الحياه الناس وتكلف الملايين من
اموال دافعين ضرائب
جلست بعد ظهر هذا اليوم مع جميع رؤساء
الشرطه لاوضح لهم ان لديهم دعمي الكامل في
التصرف بحسم لقمع الاحتجاجات غير
القانونيه من غير المقبول ان تتم عرقله
حياه الافراد على ايدي اقليه انانيه وجهه
نظري هي ان اولئك الذين يخالفون القانون
يجب ان يشعروا بالقوه الكامله ضدهم
الشرطه البريطانيه في صدد الحصول على
سلطات جديده لقمع الاحتجاجات التي تعتبرها
الحكومه غير قانونيه وهو ما يثير جدلا في
بلد يولي اهميه كبيره لحريه الاحتجاج
صوتت ضد التشريع الذي يمنع المتظاهرين
المتطرفين من تعطيل حياه الناس العاملين
لانه ليس الى جانب العمال سيدي رئيس
البرلمان هذا ما يريده المحافظون
سيدي رئيس البرلمان انا ضد كل من يتسببون
في الفوضى او الاضرار بخدماتنا العامه او
باقتصادنا
هي راح تكون من النوع او من الشخصيات اللي
حتكرر
هكذا طريقه الاحتجاج وكما اشرت انه هذه
مستهدفه بهذا التشريع وبالتالي بالمستقبل
حيكون اسهل ضبطها من الناحيه القانونيه
تحت طائله القوانين الجديده الجنائيا
الاحتجاج السلمي طبعا هو ما يقفل به
القانون حقوق الانسان لا تعطي الحق
بالاحتجاج التي الذي من خلاله تستخدم
القوه او العنف او الحاق الاضرار اعتقد
هذا هو الفارق الخط واضح جدا
هذا الالحاق ينتهي عندما يتجاوز اما
التشريعات عاديه او حريات لاخرين وهنا في
بريطانيا اللي بيحصل انه هذه الامور اصبحت
تعدي يعني هم
بكثير من الاحيان يعني
ينظرون الى هذه كاقليه من المحتجين ياخذون
الاحتجاج الى مستوى
غير مسبوق بحيث انه بيستخدموا الطرق
واساليب تكاد تكون عسكريه في طريقتها
وهناك ايضا يعني مجازفه بالطريقه التي
يمارسون فيها حق الاحتجاج وهناك سخب
وصرخات عاليه تزعج
الاخرين وهناك اضرار
للاملاك الخاصه وهذه كلها تعتبر تجاوز على
الخط المحدد للممارسات ممارسه حق التعبير
وممارسه احق الاحتجاج
لا احد يقول انه يعتقد ان التغير المناخي
ليس مهما وانما ما يقوله الناس انهم
يختلفون مع طريقه المحتجين لكن ما يمكن
قوله انه اذا نظرنا عشره سنوات الى الامام
حيث سيكون لدينا المزيد من التغير المناخي
وستكون الحوادث اقوى سيكون من المرجح ان
الناس المستعده لجذب الانتباه وزياده
الوعي سيبداون افضل من الناس الذين لم
يفعلوا ذلك
[موسيقى]
في ساعات الصباح الاولى نتوجه لنلتقي
مجموعه من الناشطين وحقوقه الحيوانات
الذين اخذوا على عاتقهم مواساه وانقاذ
قطيع من الحيوانات قبل توجههم الى المسالخ
هنا في بريطانيا
بعيدا عن ضجه لندن تقع مسالخ الحيوانات
ومزارعها توجهنا الى بلده اسكس التي تبعد
نحو الساعه والنصف التقينا كونر بريطاني
يقيم ويعمل هنا وفي وقت فراغه يقوم بوقفه
احتجاجيه شهريه من امام مسلخ للحيوانات في
بلده برنتود مع مجموعه من
الناشطينك لقد دفعنا الى تصديقي ان لدى
المملكه المتحده معايير رفاهن للحيوانات
هي بين الافضل في العالم لكنها انجح
حملاتنا في التسويق الحقيقه ان ذلك مضلل
بالكامل ولا يمثل الحقيقه كل تحقيقات التي
يقوم بها المدافعون عن حقوق الحيوان تجد
الاستغلال والقسوه والمعاناه منتشره بشكل
واسع في القطاع واشار احصاء جديد
لانيمالتي ولو فاونديشن انيمال الى ان
واحده من اصل 300 مزرعه التي قدمت جماعات
حقوق الحيوان تقارير بشانها ادت الى
محاكمه وذلك في فتره اربع سنوات ونحن
نصفها هؤلاء لم يتم التحقيق في امرهم حتى
فرغم ان لدينا القانون الى انه لا يطبق
[موسيقى]
انه امر صعب للغايه اريد فقط ان اكون هنا
من اجلهم بقدر ما استطيع اريد اخبار
الجميع كيف هو الوضع الناس لا يعرفون يقال
لهم انهم يقتلون بطريقه انسانيه ليست هناك
طريقه انسانيه ويمكنك سماعهم يمكنك سماع
صرخهم وهذه الحيوانات ذكيه لدرجه انهم
محطمون يمكنك رؤيه ذلك في وجوههم انتظري
حتى ترين وجوههم انهم مكسورون عندما يصلون
الى هنا وهم يعرفون وهذا صعب حقا
[موسيقى]
لدينا من الحلول البسيطه للكثير من
المشكلات التي تواجه الكوكب كتدهور التنوع
البيولوجي والحياه البريه وتدمير الغابات
والفيضانات وتقلبات المناخ التي تحدث
يمكننا انهاء كل ذلك بالتحول الى ان نكون
نباتيين ان الامر يتجاوزني لناحيه اقناع
الحكومه ان تستثمر بمستقبل نباتي
يصارعون من اجل مستقبل النبتي وبالفعل
الهم العديد من الشخصيات المعروفه او
سلاسل المطاعم الشهيره التي لم يخيل لك ان
تستغني عن وجباتها المذقله باللحوم الى
اتباع نظام النباتي
فجهوده هؤلاء لم تذهب سدا وقد يكون
المفتاح ليس في قضيه احتجاجهم وانما في
العثور على طرق احتجاج تصل الى قناعات
الناس وتساعد العالم في التقليل من الاثار
البيئيه التي يتسبب فيها استهلاك اللحوم
كما يؤمنون وكما تقول الدراسات العلميه
[موسيقى]